I've heard many ridiculous things in my
life but I can't think of anything more
nonsensical than arguing that democracy
will spell the end
of democracy
so let's try to analyze what we just
heard without committing ourselves to a
psychiatric hospital one liberal said
you put McCarthy back in democracy is
over
McCarthy is a husband and a father he
worked his way through school small
business owner staffer for a member of
Congress then a California state
legislator and now a member of Congress
how did he get to be a member of
Congress could it be that he was elected
as in elected by the people of
California and wouldn't that be sort of
like democracy
and to become the Speaker of the House
your party must be in the majority and
that too would be sort of like democracy
there would be no speaker McCarthy if
not for democracy so this liberal TV
personality is literally arguing that
democracy is the end of democracy
Ted Lou says democracy is on the ballot
that's profound ballots November gosh
that sounds a lot like an election
s are when the people get to speak
that's sort of textbook democracy so
it's always on the ballot because it's
the reason there is a ballot
and Ted Lou and Kevin McCarthy come from
the same state
so how can one election be democracy at
work and the other not the
and then there's George Stephanopoulos
who was the campaign manager for Bill
Clinton Clinton won the White House with
less than 50 percent of the popular vote
but that's still democracy Donald Trump
won 30 States in 2016. Hillary Clinton
won 20. Trump won the Electoral College
that's the way our system works in 2020
Trump won about half the states but he
lost the Electoral College that's still
the way our system works if he runs in
2024 and wins The Electoral College he
will be president again because that's
the way our system works
to the prophets of Doom on the left how
can it be the end of democracy when a
republican wins but democracy at work
when a Democrat wins either you believe
in our system or you do not either you
trust the people or you do not either
you believe in self-governance or you
only believe in it when you like the way
it turns out
there are threats to our democracy which
abound
democracies don't typically last and we
are wise to evaluate the strength of
ours
but the biggest threat to our democracy
is when you stop believing in it the
biggest threat is relativism it's this
notion that when I Prevail it's
legitimate but when the other side
prevails it's fraudulent
politicians in both parties have
embraced this dangerous practice of
claiming they cannot lose
you've heard both Republicans and
Democrats claim they cannot lose an
election the only way I can lose is if
it's stolen the only way I can lose is
if the other side cheats that's a threat
to democracy
the people decide who wins and who loses
not the candidates Abraham Lincoln lost
if Lincoln can lose
so can you
Ronald Reagan lost if Ronald Reagan can
lose so can you
for that matter we just celebrated
Easter and part of that story is the
crowd choosing Barabbas over Jesus if
the Son of God can lose a Voice vote to
a notorious criminal
you can lose too
the irony of liberal politicians and
commentators musing about the end of
democracy these are some of the same
folks who wanted to impeach a president
on a straight party line vote
these are some of the same folks who
wanted a parliamentarian to allow them
to achieve through Senate rules what
they could not achieve at The Ballot Box
these are some of the same folks who
belittled that half of the country who
have a different view on the size and
scope of government these are some of
the same people who are okay with Kamala
Harris being the third senator from
California but God forbid Joe manchin
act like a senator from West Virginia
one liberal magazine accused Mansion of
bailing out on saving democracy
Joe manchin represents a state where Joe
Biden and Kamala Harris did not win a
single solitary County not one
so how could it be the death of
democracy for Joe manchin to represent
the views of those who elected him
because that kind of sounds exactly like
democracy to me not the death of it
there are threats to our form of
government both internal and external
it's the internal ones that should worry
us the most the ones who claim only I
can win the ones who claim if I lose
democracy is over
democracy will never be the end of
democracy refusing to accept the results
of an election Maybe
relativism
maybe fear maybe but literally half the
country because they disagree with you
Maybe
disrespecting the rule of law
Maybe
politicians in a media we no longer
Trust
Maybe
but I can assure you democracy will
never be the end
of democracy hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else